de l'escrime à l'estime une réponse à la
récidive documentaire réalisé par nilsta
Vernier un exemple réussi vous venez de
le voir d'une forme de justice
restaurative mise en oeuvre au Sénégal à
Thiès non loin de Dakar en grande partie
grâce à l'association pour le sourire
d'un enfant dirigé par Nelly Robin
encore peu connu la justice restaurative
et pourtant entrée dans la loi française
voilà maintenant huit ans de quoi
parle-t-on exactement et quel bilan
peut-on essayer d'en tirer aujourd'hui
nous allons tenter d'y répondre avec nos
invités présents maintenant sur ce
plateau de débat doc avec vous pour
commencer Laurence vigilewski bienvenue
vous êtes député MoDem du Puy-de-Dôme
ancienne magistrate bien entendu et
aussi ancienne vice-présidente de la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale Stéphane Jacquot est également
avec nous bienvenue vous êtes juristes
fondateur de l'Association nationale de
la justice réparatrice et mer adjoint du
Parti radical de échantillon Châtillon
c'est en région parisienne c'est dans
les Hauts-de-Seine expliquez-nous en
deux mots la différence entre justice
réparatrice et justice restaurative en
réalité oui c'est la même chose lorsque
j'ai fondé mon association il n'y avait
pas encore une dénomination officielle
inscrite dans la loi et c'est vrai que
alors en bon juriste j'ai préféré donc
intitulé justice réparatrice parce que
on a déjà dans notre disons dans dans
nos mécanismes et juridiques cette
notion de réparation effectivement après
lorsque donc le la justice restera-t-il
réparatrice a évoluer en France on est
allé vers plutôt l'appellation justice
restaurative qui est d'ailleurs
intitulée de cette façon là au Canada et
qui est plus lié à la restauration du
lien alors c'est le terme justice
restaurative qui prévaut en France et
d'ailleurs ceux et celles qui nous
regardent aujourd'hui vont pouvoir le
vérifier
tout simplement en allant Google lisez
évidemment trouver les deux termes et on
va choisir celui nous de justice
restaurative puisque de la loi de la loi
française puisque effectivement ce terme
correspondent à la même approche
oliviament c'est également avec nous
bienvenue à vous vous êtes porte-parole
de la fédération France victime combien
de membres dans votre association Olivia
Mons la Fédération regroupe 130
associations sur l'ensemble du
territoire et nous accueillons toutes
les personnes qui s'estiment victimes
d'une infraction d'une violence 350
000 à peu près à l'année en tout cas en
2021 et nous les accueillons pour leur
donner de l'information sur leurs droits
du soutien psychologique et de
l'accompagnement social c'est un service
gratuit on participe à la politique
publique d'ado victimes sous avec une
référence au ministère de la Justice et
vous participez amplement à la mise en
place de ces procédures de justice
on va en reparler dans un instant
puisque cette justice restaurative a été
introduite dans la loi française en 2014
c'était à l'occasion de la réforme
pénale menée à l'époque par Christiane
taubirand qui était la garde des sceaux
à l'époque lance on vient de sortir de
ce film et ce qu'on peut bel et bien
parler d'une forme de justice
restaurative après le documentaire qu'on
vient de voir et cet exemple tiré du
Sénégal alors non pour moi ça n'est pas
la justice restaurative même si le débat
qui est un les débats dans le document
le documentaire que nous venons de voir
est une très belle illustration de ce
que l'on peut faire en matière de
réparation s'agissant de l'auteur d'une
infraction mais les téléspectateurs ont
constaté que les victimes n'étaient pas
là or l'idée majeure en tout cas telle
que je la comprends tel figure dans le
code pénal c'est de en présence les
auteurs et les victimes des infractions
pas nécessairement d'ailleurs l'auteur
de de l'infraction et de la victime de
cette infraction mais d'une manière
générale les auteurs d'infraction et les
victimes or dans le débat dans pardon
dans décidément dans le film que nous
que nous avons vu c'est la
reconstruction en réalité de mineurs
grâce à cette pratique qui a des vertus
c'est vrai nous avons pu le constater
assez
extraordinaire assez conséquente en
termes d'estime de soi de
responsabilisation et c'est vrai que
c'est une expérience très intéressante
en termes de prévention de la récidive
nous avons des programmes de ce type
aussi en France nous en avons
indépendamment de la justice
restaurative c'est une illustration de
ce que l'on peut faire en termes de
prévention de la récidive pour les
mineurs mais je ne crois pas que cela
s'inscrive exactement dans dans le
concept de la justice restaurative
justice restaurative l'idée c'est tout
de même d'organiser des rencontres Insou
diverses formes on y viendra peut-être
tout à l'heure entre effectivement
détenus et victimes auteur contrevenants
et victime une justice restaurative a
pour but d'offrir je cite un lieu de
parole respectueux sécurisé ou les gens
peuvent se parler ouvertement poser des
questions se répondre on va voir dans
dans quel cadre il est peut-être
utile à ce stade de préciser ce que
n'est pas la justice
restaurative à l'inverse mais ça n'est
pas la justice
régalienne que nous connaissons c'est
une alors une justice peut-être je ne
sais pas si l'appellation est absolument
juste mais en tout cas c'est une
complémentarité c'est une une méthode
complémentaire qui d'ailleurs obéit à un
certain nombre de conditions peut-être
faut-il les rappeler parce qu'on ne peut
pas mettre en présence les auteurs
d'infraction et des victimes comme ça
indépendamment du respect de certaines
conditions il faut que les auteurs aient
reconnus les infractions qu'ils ont
qu'ils ont commises il faut évidemment
le consentement des uns et des autres il
faut aussi l'intervention d'un tiers et
là aussi c'est un de mes sujets parce
que se tient n'est pas très défini il
faut l'intervention d'un tiers et de
respecter indispensable formé et il faut
le respect de la confidentialité et tout
cela évidemment demande beaucoup de
moyens et peut-être aussi une des
questions que l'on aura et que l'on a à
se poser c'est que on a peu d'évaluation
au terme de huit ans parce que c'est
vrai que c'est un dispositif qui
demande la réunion de temps de
conditions qu'on ne les réunit peut-être
pas toujours aussi facilement et qui est
très chronophage et très
et très cher en termes de moyens et je
crois que mes interlocuteurs sont
beaucoup plus beaucoup mieux placé que
moi pour répondre sur les programmes qui
ont déjà été mis en place et qui sont
très limités alors que je rappelle que 3
millions 500 000 infractions sont
commises en France par an voilà
sur le cadre la définition
la justice
restaurative n'est ni en opposition au
système pénal ni thérapeutique ni
orientée vers le pardon
ce dernier est simplement intime aux
personnes vous êtes d'accord avec cette
diminution pour compléter ce qui vient
d'être dit tout à fait il faut quand
même rappeler que si on doit parler de
de médiation pénale cela existe depuis
93 ça avait été donc une mesure proposée
par Robert Badinter et effectivement la
médiation pénale qui est une forme de
justice restaurative réparatrice c'est
donc une alternative à une poursuite où
on met en lien donc l'auteur et la
victime ou donc puisque là on est dans
un cadre qui est plutôt délictuel donc
qui est plutôt une alternative pour
qu'il y ait justement cette prise de
conscience à la part à la fois de la
part de de l'auteur pour un féminisme ça
peut être par exemple une
et après de la victime l'auteur voit
l'état post-traumatique de sa victime et
puis ça permet de provoquer une prise de
conscience moi j'ai vécu effectivement
de l'intérieur de façon très intime la
justice réparatrice qui n'était pas
encore qui était totalement méconnu en
France je suis orphelin et donc à la
suite de stage et était donc accueilli
dans une famille d'accueil et ma mère
adoptive a été assassinée après le
procès donc on a souhaité avec son époux
entrer en contact avec l'auteur on était
en 2007 donc il y avait eu peut-être une
expérimentation une première
expérimentation un premier groupe de
travail au sein du ministère de la
Justice là-dessus donc mais nous
familles de victimes quand on a demandé
donc on s'était adressé au parquet de
nous accompagner sur ce type de demande
et après à l'administration
pénitentiaire et bien il se retrouvait
en difficultés donc de par nous-mêmes on
a on est entré en contact avec l'auteur
et ensuite c'est sa maman qui nous a
répondu et qu'est-ce qui nous on n'était
pas du tout dans une démarche de pardon
ou de rédemption ou demandant une
rédemption de la part de l'auteur on
était vraiment donc dans quelque chose
qui était plutôt de l'ordre du registre
de savoir le pourquoi c'est-à-dire que
des fois le travail de justice fait que
pourtant souvent trois jours
où on pose le débat en cours d'assise
pour expliquer le passage à l'acte et
bien souvent les les victimes ressortent
où on attend beaucoup d'ailleurs ces
trois jours de débat
au sein d'une juridiction puis au bout
de quelques jours et bien on reste
encore en suspens sur ce sur ce pourquoi
du passage à l'acte dans et puis aussi
il y a beaucoup d'appréhension de se
dire bon peut-être est-ce qu'il va y
avoir un moment donné des représailles
de la part de la famille de l'auteur
est-ce que un jour si la personne sort
de prison me retrouve comment ça peut se
assez fin il y a beaucoup
d'appréhensions de la part de la victime
et c'est en ça justement que la justice
restera-t-il parce que elle est aussi
possible directement c'est-à-dire pour
l'auteur et la victime où sa famille de
pouvoir échanger dans un cadre bien
précis et pouvoir avancer notamment sur
cet aspect de de comprendre le pourquoi
du passage direct vous allez parler de
rédemption concernant les auteurs
évidemment on pense aux victimes et vous
êtes là pour nous en parler et il y a
assez peu de demandes de la part des
victimes peut-être pas assez dans le
cadre de ces procédures c'est en tout
cas ce que j'ai lu en préparant cette
émission c'est le cas quels sont les
victimes qui qui acceptent d'être
volontaire pour ce type de démarche et
cette sont-elles si nombreuses que cela
c'est des marges du côté des victimes
alors elles sont extrêmement nombreuses
puisque comme le disait Stéphane Jacquot
les victimes ont des questions
même après un procès elles sont encore
pleines de questions auxquelles le
procès n'a pas répondu donc finalement
que ce soit la démarche de Stéphane
Jacquot que ce soit la démarche de
victimes de violences conjugales de
victimes de violences sexuelles dans la
famille par exemple finalement là où les
infractions sont les plus graves vous
les conséquences psychotraumatiques
peuvent être les plus graves il y a
encore plein de questions et ce qui se
passe en réalité c'est du marché
individuel complètement libre évidemment
et spontané et non encadré et en fait
c'est aussi la base de ça qui nous a
fait prendre conscience que finalement
ces victimes allaient vers une rencontre
non encadrée non sécurisé non préparé et
c'est là où la justice restaurative et
la démarche que nous avons eu parce que
France victime a avec d'autres avec les
nappes avec l'École nationale
d'administration pénitentiaire la maison
centrale de Poissy on a fait les
premières expérimentations en 2010 2014
et 2016 et puis ça a ouvert ensuite avec
la réforme
à véritablement l'intégration de la
justice restaurative dans la loi
française et c'est on s'est vraiment
rendu compte du bienfait finalement pour
toutes ces personnes qui étaient en
demande qui avait aussi un besoin de
reconnaissance parce que quand il n'y a
pas de procès quand il n'y a pas de
finalement quand il y a un classement
sans suite
il y a plein de questions pour les
victimes et ces réponses elles vont être
apportées dans cette démarche de justice
restaurative grâce notamment à une
préparation ce qu'on peut dire quand
même dans la loi c'est que c'est pour
toutes les infractions et pour tous les
temps judiciaires c'est-à-dire depuis le
classement sans suite donc après un
dépôt de plainte un éventuel classement
sans suite pour des raisons
d'insuffisamment d'insuffisance de
caractérisation de l'infraction aussi
parce qu'il y aurait prescription de
l'action publique jusqu'au poste
sententiel c'est-à-dire après
l'exécution de la peine ou finalement
les personnes aussi bien les auteurs
condamnés que les personnes victimes
peuvent avoir envie et encore d'avoir
des réponses à leurs questions vous y
tiens un chiffre du nombre de délits par
an je crois
d'infractions
il y a combien de
de victimes parents qui se prêtent à ce
type de de procédure de on est on est à
environ on est environ à 200 250
personnes victimes qui qui ont eu
l'occasion de le fermer attention pour
avoir pour pour dire oui à la justice
restaurative encore faut-il être informé
et je crois que c'est extrêmement
important de dire que c'est un droit
pour les personnes c'est un droit qu'on
doit leur donner alors quand on dépose
plainte on a tout un tas de droits on a
le droit d'avoir un avocat bien
évidemment on a le droit d'être
indemnisé mais on a aussi un droit
d'être informé sur la justice
restaurative
restaurative elle peut être proposée
vous le disiez d'ailleurs très justement
indépendamment de la loi de 2014 qui
s'est appelé justice restaurative nous
avons des mesures dans le cadre des
alternatives aux poursuites qui
effectivement ressemble et peuvent
s'inscrire dans la justice restaurative
c'est-à-dire qu'on demande à la victime
de réparer l'infraction le cas échéant
de rencontrer l'auteur si c'est une
claque comme vous dites enfin tout cela
en revanche s'applique pour des
infractions je dirais de spectre modeste
de spectre modeste et on l'imagine mal
et vous donniez l'exemple que vous avez
vécu à titre personnel pour un
assassinat moi je ne l'imagine pas pour
ce type pour ce type d'infraction il ne
faut pas quand même oublier que notre
justice en matière pénale elle est
d'abord répressive et il ne faut pas
confondre les gens à mon sens s'il y a
un complément et si long peut prêter
l'attention qui est absolument
nécessaire aux victimes évidemment il
faut aller toujours plus loin mais en
fonction des infractions je crois que il
n'est pas toujours judicieux de mettre
en présence l'auteur et la victime
d'ailleurs la victime mais les victimes
le disent souvent les problèmes c'est
que les victimes le sait non non si si
je vous promets certaines ça fait 15 ans
qu'on expérimente ça
et notamment pour aller vers un champ
d'apaisement
mais je pense que moi j'ai une
obligation de d'aller dans un dans un
chemin
je parlerai pas vraiment je dirais pas
exactement un droit et mais plutôt une
possibilité une vraiment je pense qu'il
faut vraiment pour nos spectateurs
pénale c'est indiqué que les personnes
justiciables victimes et auteurs ont le
droit de se voir proposer une mesure de
justice respirative et d'y participer là
c'est plus clair alors non mais
effectivement je pense que alors d'une
part il faut bien comprendre pour nos
téléspectateurs qu'il s'agit pas de
remplacer la justice d'une part ça doit
être complément ça doit vraiment
applicable uniquement d'une part quand
la justice a fait son travail quand il y
a eu des décisions de justice et ensuite
ça doit être proposé comme une
possibilité pour se réparer pour que la
victime puis parfois aussi certains
auteurs font cette demande puisse le
faire et qu'il y ait donc un accord des
deux parties mais voyez là en ce moment
je vois un angle assez assez propice
pour la justice restaurative il se
trouve que je suis dans l'instant mise
en place par la Conférence d'évêque de
France qui est là pour réparer un déni
des indemnisé pardon les personnes qui
se disent de
teams
de l'Église catholique je suis non cet
instant ce président Marie de rat
d'ailleurs qui est qui est une
inspectrice générale de la justice et
bien là une fois que la justice n'a pas
pu faire son travail puisqu'il y a
souvent un délai de prescription et bien
effectivement là il pourrait y avoir un
travail de justice réparatrice mais là
encore une fois je vais insister sur le
fait de dire que c'est pas forcément une
mise en contact entre l'auteur et la
victime mais voyez moi par exemple
j'entends beaucoup de victimes dire le
statut de victime n'existe pas en France
qu'il y aurait peut-être nécessité après
un procès que quand il y a ce type de
demande de la part d'un d'une victime et
bien qu'il y ait par exemple une forme
de lettre dans cette lettre l'auteur
expliquerait expliquerait son passage à
l'acte reconnaissant ou il reconnaît que
il a fait telle personne victime on
annexe ce type de lettre donc au dossier
pénal et la victime y accède quand elle
le souhaite et bien ça pourrait être une
forme de réponse là aussi par exemple
dans le cadre des des victimes d'abus
sexuels dans l'église où il y a pas eu
de travail de justice et bien là ça
pourrait être aussi une réponse pour
pouvoir trouver une de pouvoir trouver
un chemin d'apaisement
et je trouve que c'est intéressant vous
visez
je dirais des un cadre ou un contexte
très spécifique ou la justice n'a pas pu
parvenir il y a eu on peut faire le
parallèle avec ce qui s'est passé en
Afrique du Sud aussi vous savez c'est un
peu la même le même mécanique
et sans que la justice ait pu intervenir
je dirais la justice pénale et puis
intervenir mais notre cadre à nous c'est
dans le cadre du code de procédure pénal
et du Code pénal donc il faut que parce
que il ne s'agirait pas que l'on
confonde les rôles des des uns et des
autres tout ce qui peut être fait je
dirais en faveur d'une meilleure
compréhension d'une meilleure
information de la victime on ne peut
qu'y être favorable mais je crois que en
fonction des aussi des types
d'infractions globalement à quelques
exceptions près peut-être
mettre en présence les auteurs des
infractions et les victimes ne peut pas
être enfin ne peut pas être une réponse
systématique alors
attendez pardonne-moi pardonnez-moi je
voudrais qu'on reste le terrain vous
avez raison
y a-t-il une graduation à mettre en
place dans ce type d'approche alors
là les approches qui sont en cours
concernent quel type de délits des
délits importants vous vous évoquiez
comme tout de même des délits très
importants violents sexuel violent et
inceste notamment violence conjugale
voilà armée de type braquage voilà de ce
type de fait sur lesquels ce type de
d'approche est utilisé là on est sur des
délits graves très on est sur des délits
graves et en fait l'ensemble de la
littérature parce que la France est
finalement un petit peu en retard par
rapport à la Belgique par rapport au
Canada où il y a une très longue
tradition de justice restaurative
on ne peut pas dire que ça ne convient
pas assez à ces types d'infraction bien
au contraire en fait non mais c'est ce
que j'ai lu bien au contraire mais bien
sûr bien au contraire
il semble exactement cette démarche
donne de meilleurs résultats parce que
il y a tellement de réponses le procès
pénal est extrêmement important je vous
rejoins là-dessus et la justice
restaurative est totalement
complémentaire à la réponse pénale qui
doit qui doit s'intéresser au passé de
l'acte c'est comment ça s'est passé quel
était l'intention etc la justice
restaurative elle s'intéresse à l'avenir
des personnes elle s'intéresse au
répercussions des personnes et ça la
justice pénale ne peut pas le faire donc
si elle va le faire en indemnisant donc
ça c'est pas le pénal c'est le civile
mais on va en indemnisant et en essayant
de réinsérer l'auteur la justice
restaurative va permettre d'un côté
d'avoir une responsabilisation de
l'auteur et de l'autre côté de la
victime une forme de reconnaissance une
victime qui peut dire à son agresseur ou
à une personne moi j'ai accompagné des
rencontres groupales détenus victimes
donc des personnes qui ne se connaissent
pas je les ai accompagné en milieu
carcéral
qu'une femme victime de viol vous après
cinq séances bah écoutez
finalement lui l'a pris perpète moi j'ai
pu lui dire des choses moi aussi j'ai
pris perpète il s'est rendu compte de ce
qu'il avait pu faire et moi ça m'a fait
du bien ça a redonné de l'estime à
moi-même ça m'a permis de revenir dans
la société c'est extrêmement important
et les ce qu'on appelle les médiations
restauratives donc un auteur et sa
victime je peux vous donner une un
exemple une extrêmement extrêmement
choquant peut-être pour vous Madame ou
pour d'autres peut-être pour ceux qui
nous regardent et peut-être
effectivement mais il faut écouter les
personnes je veux dire nous on est des
professionnels qui devons accompagner la
volonté et les attentes des personnes
moi du côté des victimes et les services
pénitentiaires du côté des auteurs moi
j'ai une femme une femme victime de
violences conjugales qui a été
extrêmement et très fortement malmené
par son ex-conjoint alors que rien ne
s'était passé pendant trois ans il est
comparution immédiate il est déféré
immédiatement mais elle a plein de elle
a plein de questions cette femme elle ne
sait pas ce qui s'est passé donc
évidemment qu'est-ce qu'elle va faire
elle demande à avoir des réponses si
elle n'est pas encadrée si on ne la
prépare pas à ses réponses à ce qui va
se passer ce qui va pas se passer ce
qu'il avait accepté par accepter demain
elle se pointe au parloir et puis elle
en prendra peut-être elle aura une autre
réponse mais qui sera extrêmement
difficile douloureuse et là ce qui s'est
passé c'est que ça il y a pas une
rencontre mais il y a eu des échanges de
questions de réponses via les
facilitateurs formés et ça s'est très
bien passé en tout cas ce qu'elle nous a
dit ça avait répondu à ces questions
alors par rapport à ce vécu ça
correspond pas tout à fait à ce que j'ai
entendu chez vous
mais pas du tout en doute évidemment cet
exemple ou cette situation particulière
mais ce que je dis c'est que ça ne peut
se faire au cas par cas et moi dans ma
pratique j'ai beaucoup plus connu de
victimes alors de violences conjugales
qui voulait surtout ne plus être en
contact avec l'auteur de la fraction les
bracelets anti rapprochement etc ce sont
même les réponses pénales qu'on a donné
mais qui ont été demandés par les femmes
demandées par les femmes bien sûr alors
cela signifie pas que dans certains cas
il peut y avoir une demande de la
victime qui soit autre mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que les les ces cas-là
sont assez
peu nombreux il faut attendre ils sont
peu nombreux par rapport à la masse des
infractions commises et je pense qu'il
faut attendre le retour des
expérimentations qui sont en cours pour
peut-être avoir un peu plus de recul moi
je crois que ça ne peut être qu'un
examen au cas par cas et d'ailleurs je
crois qu'il y a même eu des difficultés
sur certains programmes pour trouver
suffisamment de victimes volontaires
volontaires mais tout à fait mais encore
faut-il qu'elle le sache et on a fait
une expérience avec avec notre
partenaire qui est l'Institut français
pour la justice restaurative on a appelé
200 personnes 200 personnes dans le
cadre du bureau d'adovic Games en leur
proposant de leur expliquer ce que
c'était et bien sur ces 200 personnes
50% disaient pas j'adore j'adhère j'y
vais etc mais disait ça m'intéresse
peut-être pas maintenant mais plus tard
j'ai encore des questions j'ai besoin
d'avancer j'ai besoin d'être informé
donc ça c'est extrêmement important
l'information est cruciale pour offrir à
toutes les personnes un droit dont ils
peuvent bénéficier il nous reste cinq
minutes il est très peu je voudrais
quand même con parce qu'il nous reste
que 5 minutes malheureusement et on
pourrait continuer à avoir cette
transitions mais tout le monde
s'intéresse sur le évidemment
s'interroge sur le bilan ça fait 8 ans
que c'est dans la la loi française
bilan très positif concernant
la non récidive c'était ce qui
ressortait de l'exemple qu'on a vu dans
ce documentaire peut-être discutable en
termes de justice restaurative mais
c'était le bilan c'était pas du tout de
récidive dans dans cette initiative
frise au Sénégal 8 ans plus tard est-ce
qu'on peut tirer un bilan concernant la
récive bien sûr la non récidive surtout
à la mise en place de ces démarches il
est prouvé que quand il y a eu une
expérience de justice restaurative
qu'elle soit collective ou qu'elle soit
individuelle il n'y a pas de récidive en
effet mais je crois qu'il est important
vraiment de se concentrer aussi sur la
demande des victimes
c'est tangible c'est des effectivement
des parcours qui ont été accompagnés et
qui ont été aussi accompagnés par par
France victime par aussi des
scientifiques il y a un comité
scientifique autour de ça et puis
l'administration pénitentiaire qui suit
ça aussi de près d'accord mais je pense
qu'il est important vraiment aussi de
comprendre que ce dispositif qui est
aussi quand même la tournée vers les
victimes et bien c'est enfin une qui
apporte une réponse aux victimes et
cette réponse elle est fondamentale pour
ceux alors il faut pas la généraliser
cette pratique il faut savoir qu'elle
existe et que beaucoup de victimes
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser
qu'ils veulent se tenir très éloigné des
faits à un moment donné ont besoin de
savoir le pourquoi du passage à l'acte
pour se reconstruire et pour une fois
nous avons effectivement un dispositif
aujourd'hui officiel dans notre loi qui
permet justement aux victimes quand
elles le souhaitent de pouvoir donc
avoir des éléments de réponse un bout de
réponse le procès là pour ça mais
parfois il est pas suffisant la députée
est-ce qu'elle a eu le temps de jeter un
œil sur ce qui était le bilan c'est huit
années et
certainement
de documentation que je leur ai souhaité
mais je crois que le bilan est trop
modeste aujourd'hui pour que l'on puisse
en tirer véritablement des conséquences
et donc c'est une initiative
intéressante je crois qu'il faut bien la
distinguer de notre justice notre
réponse pénale notre justice pénale
régalienne et il faut toujours garder à
l'esprit
l'idée que nous sommes plusieurs
dizaines de millions en France
d'habitants et qu'il y a plusieurs
millions d'infractions commises et que
donc il faut aussi évaluer en termes de
moyens
la pertinence d'un dispositif au regard
de la réponse
positive qui pourrait en ressortir en
termes de récidive voilà je pense qu'il
faut être prudent
moi j'ai juste une réponse à ça c'est
que la justice restaurative a fait ses
preuves à l'international elle a fait
ses preuves en France sur un mieux-être
des personnes
et puis surtout ce que j'ai envie de
envie de vous dire c'est que et surtout
la France si vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure a fait le choix de proposer ce
type de dispositif sur les délits
importants les délits graves ce qui est
pas le cas de toutes les pays
aujourd'hui utilise
sur toutes les infractions mais
effectivement en fait le besoin des
justiciables et plus important dans les
infractions les plus graves dans les
homicides involontaires d'accident de la
circulation par exemple ou c'est
extrêmement où ça ça a été fait
c'est peut-être un type d'infraction
assez propice à ce type mais beaucoup
d'autres beaucoup d'autres madame
des jeunes
[Musique]
la population la protection pour
laquelle convient parfaitement ce type
de démarche en fait population en
général que ce soit les mineurs ou les
majeurs on peut se dire qu'on est
d'accord sur le fait que ça ne convient
pas à tout le monde et il faut informer
les personnes la Protection judiciaire
de la Genèse l'École nationale de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
forment ces ces
éducateurs forment l'École nationale de
la magistrature forme ces magistrats
l'École Nationale de l'Administration
Pénitentiaire forme également les
services d'insertion et de probation et
puis les directeurs d'établissements
pénitentiaire à la justice restaurative
il y a véritablement un investissement
et j'en finirai par là si vous en êtes
d'accord je comprends que vous disiez
madame que ça coûte cher au regard du
peu de population auquel ça peut
bénéficier mais en réalité si on
informait et on a commencé de le faire
quand on informe toutes les personnes en
tout cas victimes de notre côté qu'elles
ont ce droit de justice restaurative et
que ça a du sens pour elle elles vont
cheminer elles vont progresser un petit
peu elles vont se rapprocher un peu de
la justice même quand elle sentent qu'il
y aurait comme un déni de justice elle
se rapproche de la justice donc c'est
déjà une chose extrêmement importante
restaurative peut avoir donné
l'impression de coûter cher mais en
réalité si on a moins de récidive si on
a moins d'échec scolaires chez les
enfants mais si on a moins de
destruction de cellules familiales ça
fait gagner de l'argent à l'état bon ça
sera le mot de la fin je vous remercie
vraiment à toutes les trous tous les
trois d'avoir participé à ce débat d'eau
qu'aujourd'hui autour de cette fameuse
justice restaurative dont nous avons
parlé après ce documentaire tourné au
Sénégal et puis j'en profite pour dire
que tous ceux qui souhaitent se
renseigner sur l'action de cette
association pour le sourire d'un enfant
que nous avons vu dans le documentaire
que nous avons proposé ils peuvent aller
sur le site
www.enfant
sourire.com ils peuvent aussi donner à
cette association pour que cette
initiative perturbe perdure pardon du
côté de Thiès c'est à 30 km de Dakar vos
réactions à cette émission et à ces
démarches de justice restaurative ça
sera sur hashtag des Badoc sur Twitter
merci aussi à sel massali qui m'a aidé
comme à la coutumée à présenter cette
émission je vous donne rendez-vous pour
un prochain débat doc et ça sera bien
sûr avec son documentaire et son débat à
très bientôt
[Musique]